Українські військові змушені економити боєприпаси,
поки не надійшли поставки
зброї від партнерів України.
Командир українського танкового взводу в Донецькій області
рахує кожен снаряд для танка Т-64.
(Наші військові) мають думати про те, чи знищити цей міномет
зараз 3-4 пострілами. А потім не буде вистачати десь в іншому місці,
де буде серйозніша ситуація. Чи краще потримати,
пережити цей міномет, намагатися знищити його з кулеметів,
снайперською боротьбою…
Намагаємося економити боєприпаси для того, щоб у випадку,
якщо буде прорив, ми могли потім протиставити якусь силу.
Ми не можемо знищувати кожну ціль, яку виявляємо.
За словами командира, перемога України залежатиме від того,
наскільки швидко
українські військові
отримають зброю від партнерів.
Якщо ми не отримаємо тої кількості озброєння, яка нам необхідна,
то ми будемо далі утримувати не дуже добру позицію.
Ця війна може дуже сильно затягнутися.
Все залежить від швидкості поставки озброєння зараз. Тут і зараз.
У нас з цього моменту є ще пів року для того, щоб ми могли активно
вести контрнаступ в адекватних умовах і з мінімумом жертв.
До осінніх дощів. Після - нам так само буде важко наступати, як і їм.
У ЄС домовилися надати Україні артилерійських боєприпасів
на два мільярди євро. Перша партія складе один мільйон снарядів,
які мають надійти впродовж року.
Це стратегічний крок. Це те, що додає впевненості в нашій єдності,
в незмінності руху до перемоги над державою-терористом.
Дякую усім нашим партнерам в Європі. Усім, хто дійсно зацікавлений,
щоб Європа була сильною і вільною.
Оголошено сьогодні й про новий оборонний пакет від США.
Обсяг - 350 мільйонів доларів. Це ракети для HIMARS, артилерійські
та інші боєприпаси. Все, що дійсно необхідно, щоб підтримати наших воїнів.
За оцінками військового експерта Романа Світана,
обіцяного ЄС мільйона снарядів має вистачити
на три місяці наступальних дій ЗСУ.
За добу українська армія використовує 5 тисяч снарядів
- це в оборонному режимі. А для наступального потрібно
близько 10 тисяч. Тобто приблизно потрібно близько 300 тисяч снарядів
на місяць, а це означає, що мільйон снарядів буде витрачено
при наступі за три місяці. Тобто мільйон снарядів - це тримісячний
запас снарядів для виконання наступальних дій.
А це виконання одного наступу або одного етапу наступу
- із визволенням Криму.
У Брюсселі міністри закордонних справ ЄС домовилися надати Києву
мільйон снарядів калібру 155 міліметрів.
Вони використовуються у західних видах артилерії,
які союзники передають Україні.
Проте деяким країнам доведеться буквально спустошити склади.
Адже Європа не готувалася до війни.
Останні 20 років після закінчення холодної війни ми, європейці,
скорочували нашу військову міць.
Факт у тому, що ми скоротили наші військові витрати вдвічі.
І згідно з нашими даними, витрати на виробництво боєприпасів
були скорочені вчетверо. А тепер раптово нам треба збільшувати їх
через обстановку, що радикально змінилася.
За словами німецького міністра оборони, боєприпаси буде закуплено
як у рамках національних програм, так і в рамках єдиного
європейського замовлення.
Наша першочергова мета - і вона має абсолютний пріоритет -
відправити значну кількість боєприпасів в Україну до кінця року.
Артилерія відіграє ключову роль у протистоянні, в якому ані Росія,
ані Україна не можуть на повну силу використати авіацію.
Справа в тому, що 90 відсотків поразки в такого роду війнах,
коли не використовується авіація - а у нас немає авіації для того,
щоб використовувати її, а росіяни не можуть свою авіацію
використовувати, бо у нас дуже сильна система ППО -
ми просто не даємо їм її використовувати.
І невикористання авіації вивело на перше місце використання артилерії.
І повернуло так званим "богам війни" їхній п'єдестал.
Тема дефіциту снарядів в українській армії настільки важлива,
що про неї навіть говорив канцлер Німеччини Шольц,
виступаючи нещодавно перед депутатами Бундестагу.
Європейцям ще кілька років тому здавалося, що масштабна війна
в Європі така малоймовірна, що снаряди більше не потрібні.
Тепер у ЄС обговорюють схему централізованої закупівлі снарядів,
аналогічну до закупівель вакцини від коронавірусу.
Тим часом, за даними Стокгольмського міжнародного
інституту дослідження проблем миру, третина всіх поставок зброї в Україну
- зі США, 17 відсотків з Польщі та 11 - німецьке озброєння.
До 2022 року Україна була незначним одержувачем зброї,
незважаючи на ситуацію, в якій вона знаходилася.
Але зараз ми бачимо, що вона збільшила імпорт зброї, чи, краще сказати,
отримала багато зброї від цілої низки європейських держав та США,
і ми бачимо, що за останній рік вона стала значним отримувачем зброї.
Місяць тому Федеральна рада безпеки Німеччини схвалила
постачання Україні 178 модернізованих танків "Леопард 1"
з промислових запасів. А до річниці початку війни Берлін анонсував
ще постачання 4 танків Леопард 2А6.
28 лютого німецький концерн Rheinmetall повідомив,
що системи ППО Skynex та Skyranger теж були відправлені в Україну.
Також Варшава активно постачає Україні танки.
27 січня прем'єр-міністр Польщі заявив, що, крім 14 танків Леопард 2,
Польща поставить Україні ще 30 танків T-72M та 60 танків PT-91.
А Міноборони США у річницю початку війни оголосило про новий пакет
військової допомоги Україні обсягом 2 мільярди доларів.
Ідеться про боєприпаси для реактивних систем залпового вогню HIMARS
та ракетних систем з лазерним наведенням, кілька типів дронів,
обладнання для виявлення засобів радіоелектронної боротьби,
артилерійські боєприпаси, а також обладнання
для розмінування місцевості.